let's bring in the mayor of Mesa Arizona
John Giles mayor Kyle's good morning to
you what do you think about the borders
are coming to your home state of Arizona
not visiting the Border
well the the uh the story that she's
there to celebrate in Tonopah about the
electric grid is a great story and and
so we we appreciate that but it is a
lost opportunity to visit the border and
to bring attention to the security
issues that we're facing the the drugs
that are coming across the border are
absolutely impacting my city of Mesa
Arizona uh in the last two months we've
recovered over 800 000 fentanyl tablets
in Mesa over 200 pounds of
methamphetamphetamine just last month
and these are borders that are these are
drugs that are coming across the border
into our community so there's absolutely
security issues at the border that we
would love for the vice president to uh
to to bring more attention to and to
bring more resources to also where as
everyone knows we're facing a surge of
migrants due to the lack of of updated
immigration laws the when title 42 goes
away shortly we're going to see a an
extreme surge at the border of migrants
so we've got as you indicate a crisis at
our border we've got we need more
Federal attention I agree with mayor
Adams the criticism of the lack of of
leadership at the border but and that
applies to the administration but also
the the reforms that we need have to
come through Congress so there's there's
blame to to be shared all over
Washington D.C well you mentioned mayor
Adams he just visited uh the Border El
Paso Texas and he just wrote a
Washington Post op-ed about the Border
issue which is really interesting to
have the Democratic New York city mayor
writing an op-ed about this border
crisis because he says that it's going
to be costing New York City 2 billion
dollars to deal with all the migrants
that are are flooding into the Big Apple
and he says what I found in El Paso was
exactly what I feared the national
crisis has left local governments and
Grassroots organizations along the
border struggling to adequately care for
the migrants coming into their
communities what do you think about that
statement from mayor Adams
well I'm in Washington DC right now at
the U.S Conference of mayor's conference
I was with mayor Adams yesterday uh in
in the conference on this topic and I
appreciate very much the uh the energy
that he's bringing to this issue New
York City has received over 40 000
migrants over the last few months so uh
this is an issue that uh in in border
states we've been uh lighting ourselves
on fire trying to get attention in
Washington DC for decades now so I very
much appreciate mayor Adams entering the
the debate uh this is an issue that's
been overlooked for decades by
Washington D.C
John Giles thank you so much for joining
us this morning we appreciate it I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis